>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Stephen Winick: Welcome,
we're here at the
Library of Congress.
My name is Stephen
Winick and I'm here
with my colleague, Valda Morris.
We both work in the
American Folklife Center
at the Library of Congress.
And we're here interviewing
Barbara Freeman,
who is a prominent storyteller,
who's been telling stories
around the country for --
>> Forty-eight years.
>> Stephen Winick:
Forty-eight years.
>> Valda Morris: Wow.
>> Stephen Winick: So, we're
interested, first of all,
in your -- in your early life
and what got you
interested in storytelling.
>> Barbara Freeman: Well, I
was always the kid on the block
that had the lemonade stand.
And, so, I learned from my
dad, too, he was a joke teller.
I didn't always understand
his jokes,
which I think was a
blessing as a little girl.
But, my family always told
stories, but on each other.
Remember the time I took the
cabbage and threw it at you
because you did this, you
know, that sort of thing.
So, that was an early beginning.
And, in high school and
elementary school and college,
I would always enter these,
you know, performance things
where you get up and
make a fool of yourself,
and I was very comfortable doing
that, and I got a few prizes.
So, that was an encouragement.
And then I loved to listen to
Martha Ray and Carol Burnett
and other comedians, and so
I could see what kind joy
that brought me to hear them.
And, so, I wanted to do
that for other people, too.
So, that was kind of a
background for storytelling.
Plus, I worked at the
library in Chattanooga
as a research librarian,
not official
with any paperwork though.
I was just a schoolteacher that
decided to be at the library.
And, as a schoolteacher, I
taught reading and told stories
to my seventh and
eighth grade class,
and I was the only white
teacher in an all-black school
in Chattanooga, Tennessee.
And that -- being
from Tennessee,
it's the volunteer state,
so I volunteered to be one
of the first teachers, you know,
so we were no longer segregated.
And, so --
>> Valda Morris: Wow.
>> Barbara Freeman:
I loved that,
and I loved telling
my kids stories,
and I got a letter right
after I stopped teaching
and went into the library.
I actually wanted to work
with the government to go
to disadvantaged
neighborhoods and tell people
to buy their kids library books,
or give them library books,
because I thought
that was so important.
But, they wanted me not
to do the fieldwork.
They wanted me to be in office
and do interviews and stuff
like that, and I
said, no, I want to be
in the field somewhere.
So, I got the job at the
library as a research librarian,
and then I was encouraged
to go to library school.
And they wrote a letter for
me, so I got a full fellowship.
And, so, that was wonderful,
because I failed
all the math exams.
I did. I did.
They thought I didn't
take the test [laughter].
They said, you aced the English,
but were you sick
for the math part?
And I said, no, I filled
it out as best I could.
But, they gave me a chance
anyway on a fellowship.
So, I got my degree
in library science.
And then they asked me to
be children's librarian
at Chattanooga, Tennessee.
>> Valda Morris: Nice.
>> Barbara Freeman: So,
I got to tell stories
to all the little
elementary kids.
And then asked me to be
the young adult librarian,
head of that department, so
I got to tell the teenagers,
the college right next
door and the students came
over for drama classes,
and all like that,
so I got to tell
it to the older.
And then I was being
asked to come
and do young adult
book conferences
and give a workshop
on storytelling.
And, meanwhile, Connie [assumed
spelling] came up to visit me
and she said, I -- you know,
I don't have a real job.
I've just been in Europe
traveling in my Volkswagen.
And I said, well,
we need another --
we need somebody to tell
stories to disadvantaged kids
that economically are poor
and make them love books.
So, we'll give you a
little book mobile.
You will be called Miss
Daisy [assumed spelling].
You will wear a daisy outfit on
your blue dress, and you'll go
to these neighborhoods and tell
stories and hand them books.
And, if the books come back
destroyed because there's five
or six kids in the same
bed, then you just tell him,
honey, here's another book.
Just put it on top
of your refrigerator.
We want them to love reading
and, you know, love the books.
So, Connie did that
for three years.
I was already there at
the library for a year.
So, after four years we
said, pooey [phonetic],
we're being asked to come to
folk music festivals and stuff
and that looks like fun.
Let's become traveling
professional storytellers.
>> Valda Morris: Oh.
>> Barbara Freeman: And we did.
>> Valda Morris: Wow,
so, that was amazing.
So, how did you -- tell me
about your life on the road.
Like, so, you packed up.
You decided to leave your
job after so many years jobs.
>> Barbara Freeman:
Yeah, jobs we loved.
>> Valda Morris: Yeah, and then,
so, how did you finance that?
>> Barbara Freeman: Well,
we didn't have a job --
or, when we -- when we
quit our jobs and cashed
in our life insurance and
sold everything we owned.
And, I had a Datsun
pickup truck.
We put a little topper on it
and we were down the road.
But, we had tickets to a major
folk festival near Woodstock
in New York, Fox Hollow,
and they had famous people.
You know, Joan Baez type
people and stuff like that.
So, we got there as audience,
and our campground was
flooded that night.
It was --
>> Valda Morris: Wow.
>> Barbara Freeman:
The water was rising
from the Little Hoosic creek
all the way up, like three feet.
And, so, they knocked on the
door of our camper and said,
get out of here, get
out of here fast.
And it's like, oh, Connie,
we -- Connie says, now, now.
She's very organized.
And, so, we drove out through
the water and the flood
and there was a person at the
end of the campground who said,
you all come and camp with
the professional music people,
the performers, the stars,
and you can have a
little spot there.
So, we met people during
the day, and at night we set
up a campfire and we had told
a lot of the stars and a lot
of people at the
festival, just come over,
we're going to tell stories.
We're traveling storytellers.
And at that campfire was Sandy
Patton from Folk Legacy Records,
and he said, and other
people, Bob Zentz,
I mean some famous
people, and they said,
come on to Connecticut
next week.
We're having a festival.
We've already got
all our booking,
but if we have time we'll
put you on the stage.
And we got there and he said,
we've only got time for one
of you, and we'll
put you on the stage.
And, so, they asked
me to tell Wicked John
and the Devil, and I did.
So, we couldn't get off the
stage before people were coming
up to us saying, I run a
coffee house in California,
and I'll fly you out to New
York for my coffee house.
And, a teacher came up and said,
I have a daycare center right
down the street and
I want to hire you
to come tomorrow morning.
So, and Bob Zentz said, I've got
the Old Dominion Festival next
month and, I not only want you
to come there and tell stories,
but I want you to
go to the university
and teach a six-month
course on storytelling.
>> Valda Morris: Wow.
>> Barbara Freeman:
So, you know,
we didn't have a business card.
We didn't have a name then.
But, in Connecticut
actually, somebody said, well,
if you're concerned about
the word storytelling,
meaning it's going to
just be for three, four,
and five-year-olds, why don't
you just call yourself The Folk
Tellers, and then it's
for all the folks.
So, that was cool.
And then another wonderful man
named Bob Donneller ran off
on his print machine a
little business card for us
and our first brochure,
and it was really sweet.
>> Stephen Winick:
That is sweet.
So, you mentioned Wicked
John and the Devil.
And now, from what Connie
said, you got that story
from Ray Hicks and his family.
>> Barbara Freeman: Yeah,
actually I have been telling it
at the library from
Richard Chase's book.
>> Stephen Winick:
Oh, sure, yeah.
>> Barbara Freeman:
Wicked John and the Devil.
I had been telling it
to the young adults.
And, also, from -- I actually
had gone up to near Banner Elk
where there was a
little local festival,
and I had met Ray Hicks
before he even came
to the National Storytelling
Festival
in Jonesboro, Tennessee.
But, I had met him and I had
heard him tell Wicked John
and the Devil.
And I showed him, you know,
my book and I said, gosh,
I'd really love to learn that.
And he said, well, you
learn it, you just learn it.
You know, so, I had learned it.
And then when he came a year
later to Jonesboro, Tennessee,
I asked him to tell it
again to Connie and I.
And, so, we both got to
listen to him tell it,
and he tells it much
better than I do, you know.
He's -- I mean, he's
the kingpin.
>> Valda Morris: Yeah.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah, tell
us a little about how you --
how you came to him
and work with him.
>> Barbara Freeman: Well,
having met him at Banner Elk --
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah.
>> Barbara Freeman: And
then getting with him again
at Jonesboro, Tennessee, Connie
and I really wanted to go
up there and sit on his porch
and just soak him in, you know.
And when we got there
the first time it was --
it was -- we were fascinated.
He goes from one story to the
other, and it was starting
to get dark, and it
was cold, you know.
And we were thinking,
man, we've got to go home.
But, he -- there's
no stopping with --
you know, as soon
as he gets to --
and he's been happy ever since
with his mom, then he would,
and Jack, he went looking
for a unicorn one day.
And we'd have to say,
Rosa, that's his wife.
Rosa, could you come
in here please
and tell Ray we got
to leave [laughter]?
And she would say, Ray,
now you need to hush
and let these girls go home.
Well, I'll just tell
them about [laughter] --
and, so, we went
up there so often.
And, nowadays, once a year we
have a Hicks family reunion
with all the neighbors and
friends, and Ed Stivender
from Philadelphia
drives down for it,
and lots of storytellers
will drive from all over.
And we just sit around and tell
stories and have a good time,
even though Ray and
Rosa have passed away,
and their beloved son, Ted,
died within just a
couple weeks of Rosa.
And I was with Rosa
right before she died.
I just -- I just -- we just
loved those people so much.
They're family.
>> Valda Morris: Yeah.
So, Ray has been a staple, and
his family has been a staple
in both you and Connie's lives.
>> Barbara Freeman:
And, you know, even,
I was asked to do a --
play a cast role in a
major motion picture called
Winter People.
>> Valda Morris: Oh yeah, yeah.
>> Barbara Freeman: And when
I went to do that movie,
Winter People is about the
mountain people in Appalachia.
And I said, you guys, you know,
Kelly McGillis and Kurt Russell
and Lloyd Bridges and, I
said, you all have got to go
up with me and sit on the porch
of a winter person [laughter].
And I took them up there, a lot
of the cast, to meet Ray Hicks.
>> Valda Morris: Nice.
>> Barbara Freeman: And
they were just stunned.
I mean, it was like -- they
couldn't -- they couldn't --
and they were there a long time.
>> Valda Morris: Wow.
>> Barbara Freeman:
Rosa [laughter],
these movie people have
got a movie to go to.
Can't wink [laughter].
They were so sweet.
>> Valda Morris:
So, apart from Ray,
do you have any other mentors or
other traditional storytellers
that you could attest
to and inspire you?
>> Barbara Freeman: Well, as
the years went by, yeah, a lot.
Well, like I said, in the
funny world, you know,
for me it was Martha
Ray and Carol Burnett
and other just very,
very funny people.
But, since Connie and I
were kind of the first ones
out of the gate, you
know, we didn't have any,
except Ray maybe, but we
very soon were able to travel
to St. Louis to be with
my brother and his family.
And wherever our families
were, you know, we would set
up jobs there, called
it a library and find
out what festival
they were having
and send our little brochure
and see what we could do.
So, we met Gamble Rogers,
and he mostly 90% music,
but his introductions to
his stories were phenomenal.
And we said, you have got to
come to Jonesboro, Tennessee.
And, so, he inspired me, but
he came with a lot more story
and a little bit
less music, you know.
But, he was -- I don't
know if you all know this.
But, he died holding out his
hand to save a person's life
in Saint Augustine,
Florida on the beach,
and Gamble couldn't even swim.
But, a little child
came running up,
my daddy, my daddy's drowning.
And Gamble looked and he
went out into the water,
stretched out his hand,
and pulled that man out,
but Gamble drowned, yeah.
So, and he was like that
in real life anyway.
He was always holding
out his hand to us.
>> Stephen Winick: Well, thank
you for remembering him here.
>> Valda Morris: Yes.
>> Stephen Winick: So,
you mentioned several
times the festival
that you brought Gamble
to, and other people,
the National Storytelling
Festival in Jonesboro.
Explain the importance of
that festival and setting you
on the path of being
a storyteller.
>> Barbara Freeman:
Well, the fun thing
about that festival was
that Jimmy Neil Smith,
who later became the mayor
of Jonesboro, was listening
to the radio and he heard
Jerry Clower, you know,
Marcel the chainsaw kind
of comedian on the radio.
And he said, you
know, we ought --
I'm a journalist teacher here,
I'd like to interview him.
Let's get him here and have
a storytelling festival,
and we'll have it at the high
school, maybe 3000 people.
Maybe we can pack the place.
And we'll just have a
storytelling festival
and I'm going to write to
some of the politicians,
stump speakers, and stuff like
that, and get them to come,
and we'll just have a festival.
And, meanwhile, Connie
had written to him
and he had written back and
wrote a letter to me, too,
as the nearby librarian,
and said,
you all come to the festival.
He didn't -- I don't
think he said
at that time we could tell
stories, he just said come.
So, we both went, and it was
20 people on the front porch,
you know, and we had
the stump speakers.
And then, he said, anybody
out there in the audience want
to get up here and tell a story?
Well, Connie and
I were, you know,
just running toward the stage.
We weren't telling tandem then.
So, she told a story and then
I told a story on a hay bale.
Ray Hicks got up
and told a story.
And, he stood at
that microphone,
he was a nervous wreck.
He just looked to heaven
and stuttering Jack,
he was seeking his
fortune, and all this stuff.
And I thought, oh,
this is a mistake.
This is a mistake
because the man's going
to have a heart attack
and, you know,
just got to take
everybody to him.
You can't bring him
behind a microphone,
technology, and stuff.
But, the next year, grabbed
that mic, Jack [laughter].
And, you know, he was
the star from then on.
So, it was -- it was all right.
It turns out all
right, you know.
So, that festival, Jimmy
Neil Smith asked us to be
on the Board of Directors
along with David Holt
and a few other people,
some people from PBS
that were wonderful.
And, so, we allowed
that we would.
Jimmy Neil said he
was going to call
that festival the
Podunk [phonetic] Hill
Storytelling Festival.
And we said, you know,
Jimmy Neil, this might grow
into something kind of big.
Connie and I are right here
trying to save storytelling.
That's why we quit our
jobs with the money.
And, you know, maybe call
it something really cool
like a National Storytelling
Festival, or --
oh, and the organization
could be NAPPS, N A P P S,
the National Association
for the Preservation
and Perpetuation
of Storytelling.
Like a bedtime story, a NAPPS.
And, so, that's what
it was called.
It was -- that was really good.
That was my only contribution.
Connie did all the rest
of the work [laughter].
She's organized.
>> Valda Morris:
That is really neat.
I did not realize that you all
were so instrumental in coming
up with the name and coming
up with the name of
the organization.
That's really great.
>> Barbara Freeman: Well,
we had other input, too.
I mean, we sat around
and argued [laughter].
The whole board got in on it.
>> Valda Morris: So,
you've been in the field
of storytelling for 48 years.
>> Barbara Freeman: Well,
if you count my being a
storytelling reading teacher,
you know, you can push
it up to at least 50.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Valda Morris: All right,
so you've been involved
in storytelling for
at least 50 years.
>> Barbara Freeman: Yeah.
>> Valda Morris: And you
are being [inaudible]
of what we call a revival
of storytelling,
which was nationwide.
How do you see the scene has
grown and changed over time?
>> Barbara Freeman: The
storytelling itself?
>> Valda Morris: Yes,
the telling of stories.
>> Barbara Freeman: Well, now
it seems like everybody wants
to call themselves
a storyteller.
Architects will say, I'm a
storyteller when it comes
to developing the building.
It's one story after
another [laughter].
But, you know, Tom T. Hall, the
storyteller, country singer.
So, but back in the day,
storytelling did mean, oh,
you're going to sit down with,
you know, a three-year-old
and tell them a nice little
story, read them a book.
So, now storytelling
has a whole new meaning.
We could even go out now and
call ourselves the storytellers
and be accepted, you know.
So, but there was
a real change, too,
in the fact that people
almost never talked
about their private
life on the stage.
They would tell, you know,
a story back in the day
and traditional and
folklore kind of thing.
But, then it got to be
where even some storytellers
were almost using a psychiatric
couch, you know, to bring
to the fore their alcoholic
parents or whatever.
So, a lot of things
started to change.
I think now it's come down to
the personal experience stories
are just hilarious.
They're wonderful, and
they don't get you nervous
or stressed out.
They just bring you health
and happiness, you know.
So, I think it would be
great if we went back
to the real blend
though, at least 50/50
with traditional and, you
know, personal experience.
>> Stephen Winick:
Personal experience, yeah.
So, you mentioned before
that you and Connie,
at that early stage
of your career,
you weren't telling tandem,
and then at some point
you developed this --
>> Barbara Freeman:
It was very soon.
[ Inaudible ]
When we pulled into a
Connecticut parking lot,
Bob Zentz had been in
there with Bob Donneller,
even though Bob lived in
Virginia, he was there
to perform at the festival,
which was like two days
later, or one day later.
So, we had -- we were taking
stuff out of our truck
to take it into the
copy print shop.
And, these little kids were
walking down the street
and they say, what you all
doing, because we were taking
out suitcases and we were
taking out a little limber jack,
you know, the little
dancing dolls.
I had a collection of about
80 of them, people would make
for me at the library.
So, they -- what you doing?
I said, well, we're
storytellers.
He said, storytellers?
Well, we want to hear
a story [laughter].
So, we stood there on
our tailgate of our truck
and we just said, well, why
don't we tell them Wild Things?
And we just started out
with, okay, now, you kids,
open up your closet door,
put on your wolf suit.
Now, try out a roar or two.
And they were [growling sounds].
And I said, all right, now,
we're going to tell
you this story,
because one night Max
wore his wolf suit.
And Connie said, and made
mischief of one kind.
And, I said, and another.
And his mother called
him, Wild Thing.
You know, we went
back and forth.
And, Bob Zentz was across
the street and he walked over
and he said, that's my
favorite story, you know.
I want you to tell that when
you come to Old Dominion.
So, then we thought,
well, that really worked.
Let's learn some more and
see what we can do in tandem.
So, that was -- we
started very soon.
Actually, we left our homes on
July the -- in July of 1975,
even though we had been
telling stories before.
And then, this was like
August or September.
>> Stephen Winick:
That's pretty quick.
>> Barbara Freeman: So, I mean,
right away we did
get the tandem thing.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah.
It sounds like it was
pretty easy to develop, too.
It wasn't a big labor.
>> Barbara Freeman:
It is so natural
and so your first cousin stuff.
>> Valda Morris: Yeah.
>> Barbara Freeman: You know,
it really -- it really is.
And we kind of know which
role to play, too, you know.
Sometimes we change it around.
That makes it a little
more interesting, too.
>> Valda Morris: So --
>> Barbara Freeman: We even
knew which side to sit on.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Barbara Freeman: If Connie
was in this room right now,
she'd be right here [laughter].
>> Valda Morris: Yeah.
>> Barbara Freeman: And, so, the
one that was driving the truck,
it had to be a certain one
before we could learn a story
in the truck.
>> Stephen Winick: Oh, right.
>> Barbara Freeman:
Because we couldn't --
we couldn't do it like this.
It was too confusing.
>> Valda Morris: Okay,
so, you've developed --
over the years you
developed a play.
Can you tell me about this play?
>> Barbara Freeman: Oh, the --
[ Inaudible ]
Play was so much.
There's a little
girl, 16 years old,
named Savannah Dargan
[assumed spelling].
She's been writing plays
since she was about 10.
And, her daddy is John
Basinger [assumed spelling].
And John -- they
lived in Connecticut.
And John called taught
theater at his college,
and he also wrote plays and
had, you know, produced them,
directed them, and had either
the students or famous stars
that came to Connecticut do the
theater pieces in the summer,
like summer stock kind of thing.
Well, John, we had met him
earlier and asked him to come
to Jonesboro, because he
was also an interpreter
for the hearing impaired
in sign language.
And, so, John, we asked John
to come down and help us,
give us something to make
our performance really good
so we could do a long run
somewhere in Asheville.
We could get off the road.
We'd been on the road
for so many years,
and sometimes we'd be gone for
an entire month or three weeks
or two weeks, and Connie
had just got married.
You know, she didn't
want to do that anymore.
And we were both getting a
little tired of, you know, it.
And, so, John and Savannah
came down and took our stories,
like kind of tells
this beautiful story
about two white horses, and
he taught us how to make
that a story told by our great
Aunt Jenny [assumed spelling].
So, just with a turn of the head
and just a few words, you know,
she can say, I remember
great Aunt Jenny.
She was just a little girl on
the day of her mama's funeral.
And she told us [inaudible]
Amanda Jane [assumed spelling]
fixed me with her
big brown eyes.
She would be into the story,
but we played great Aunt Jenny
and we also played -- she
played Sarah [assumed spelling]
and I played Jenny Rose [assumed
spelling], and I had to go
to Detroit to keep
the home place
from the taxes taking over.
And, so, it was a play
about us being little kids
that always gave our great
Aunt Olio [assumed spelling]
a performance.
And, when somebody
would come into town,
like Sheila Adams Barnhill, we
would have her knock on the door
of Great Aunt Jenny's house,
and we'd say, come on in, girl.
We're just about to
give our Aunt Olio --
and, so, she would
bring her banjo
and she would play
for Great Aunt Jenny.
So, sometimes the play morphed
into this wonderful invite
for other storytellers
and music people.
And, we had so many seasons, you
know, like 16 seasons of it ran,
almost eight years, or
right at eight years.
It was -- it was great.
It kept us home and we got to
the actress thing, you know.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah.
>> Barbara Freeman: Theater
is a little different
than storytelling.
Storytelling, we like the lights
up so we can see all the people
and make eye-to-eye contact.
When you're on the theater,
it's really a dialogue
between two actors and you
don't even need an audience
to have the play happen.
But, with storytelling
you've got to --
you know, you've got to have
a person to tell the story to.
So, the set was a
little bit different,
but we made it very
storytelling style in the play.
And, Good Morning America
got us to interview us
and Good Housekeeping
did a nice article on us.
And I told my folks, I said,
that's the only way I'll ever be
in Good housekeeping [laughter]
is through storytelling.
Connie has a nice [inaudible].
[ Laughter ]
>> Stephen Winick:
So, eventually you
and Connie did part
ways as storytellers.
You went on to solo careers.
How did -- how did that happen?
>> Barbara Freeman: Well, that's
kind of an interesting story,
because Connie and I like to
do everything exactly together,
after every performance
or before.
No matter where we
were, we loved to go
in stationery shops
and buy stationery.
We would love to go to yard
sales and look at the antiques.
And, we just were like two peas
in a pod, and more like sisters.
I was on an airplane one time
and I had all my scandal sheets
out in front of me, you
know, National Enquirer
and The Globe and
stuff like that.
The Globe even called me
one time and interviewed me,
and I thought it was the Boston
Globe newspaper [laughter].
And, so, I was given this
big interview over the phone
and finally they said, well,
you know, you'll be coming
out in one of our issues.
And I said, issue?
We're not even coming
to Boston, honey.
We're not doing any
performances in Boston.
And she said, we're not The
Boston Globe, we're The Globe.
And I said, the scandal sheet?
I said, what did I say?
What did I say?
Tell me what I said.
And she said, no,
you did really fine.
Well, when it came out we were
right underneath Uncle Ike's
[assumed spelling] ant farm
and a nice picture of his ants,
and it was really good.
It was really good, but that
is how my brother knew I
had arrived.
I mean, they could care
less that we were, you know,
sort of getting famous
and all this stuff.
But, when he saw in the grocery,
The Globe, with, you know,
storyteller, I mean, it had a
little headline on the cover.
And he said, surely not.
And he looked it up and saw that
it was a nice article about us
and our truck, daput [phonetic],
Datsun pickup truck,
daput, 200,000 miles.
So, I had arrived through that.
But, anyway, I'm
on this airplane
and somebody handed
me a newspaper
about a miracle happening
in Medjugorje, Yugoslavia,
a communist country, the
Blessed Virgin Mary appearing
to some children.
And I hadn't been in a church or
thought about it for 22 years,
so this is 1987 on
September the 14th.
And, so, I'm reading this paper
and it says her first message.
Dear children, I
have come to tell you
that God exists and
he loves you.
And, for some strange reason,
I knew in my heart
that it was true.
And, then I went to the
back, like I always do,
I hate to tell this
because I was a librarian,
but I always read the
ending of every book.
I don't like surprises.
So, I went to the back.
Her last message
was, dear children,
reincarnation is
a false doctrine.
You have one body and one soul.
And I thought, dang, because
I was in the New Age movement
for many years, and I
really believed in that.
And I would tell people,
look, a tulip dies
and then it comes back.
But, of course, it doesn't
come back as a giraffe,
but I thought it did it maybe.
And, two weeks before I
had been on an airplane
and the cargo door came loose
and ripped off, and Connie
and I were told, and
everybody else to get
in the crash position.
He had no idea why we
were losing altitude.
And, so, we're going down
and I look out at the Statue
of Liberty and I
said, this is so cool.
The Statue of Liberty.
I'll probably bond with this.
I may even come back as
the Statue of Liberty.
And people were praying, and
some were crying, some were kind
of humming or singing.
And, all I wanted
was a stick of gum
because my ears were popping
off the side of my head.
And I heard a lady say, I
don't want to die with gum
in my mouth, and
she took out her gun
and stuck it under her seat.
And I thought, if I wasn't
in the crash position,
I would go over there and
free up that chewing up.
People were making notes to,
I guess, their loved ones.
No note, nothing.
And then that was two weeks
before we made an emergency
landing and I didn't
die or come back
as the Statue of
Liberty, you know.
So, to fast-forward, somebody
hands me this miracle newspaper,
and I believe it, and then
our Lord took me off the plane
and he read me the riot act.
At that time I was living
with a man for four years
and we had two houses
together and two cars together.
And, our Lord said to
me, I didn't see him,
but I heard his voice
and I knew it was him.
I was kind of like
in an egg shell
or some kind of yellow mist.
And, He said, I call
it fornication
and it greatly offends me.
You must amend your life.
And he told me two other sins
I was never again to commit
and put me back on the plane.
And it was like, Lord, do
they still call you Lord?
I didn't even know
you were in history.
Look, I don't love you because
I don't know you, but I'm going
to read about you, I'm
going to discover you,
and I'm sure I'll grow to
love you but, to be honest
with you, I don't right now.
I'm just scared to
death of my destiny.
He didn't show me
hell, but my soul knew
that that's where I was headed.
So, unrepentant sin, you
know, the whole nine yards.
So, it changed my whole life.
So, then I thought I had
to fix everybody else's
life, including my family.
You ought to go to Medjugorje.
You ought to go to Yugoslavia.
It's a communist country.
You ought to go anyway.
There's a miracle over there.
And, so, I did use the
Bible, but I hammered people
over the head with it, and you
can only take so much of that.
Finally, Jesus told me,
you know, I'm the carpenter
and I fix things, not you.
But, it was hard on Connie.
It was hard on everybody.
But, I just thought, boy,
that's the best news
I've ever had in my life.
So, I really -- you know, that
changed my life that experience.
And I'm grateful for it, but
it also meant that, you know,
I said I now give you chillers,
you know, because I'm not going
to tell those dark
stories anymore.
I'm going to go for the light.
But, it was just -- and I'd
rather go to mass and go
to church then to go to
the stationery stores
or go to the yard sales.
So, I should have been a
lot more conscious of Connie
and her needs than I was
trying to make up for lost time
that I had lost with
God, you know.
So, that's -- was that
answering your question?
>> Stephen Winick:
Yes [laughter].
>> Barbara Freeman: What was
your question [laughter]?
>> Valda Morris: No,
that was perfect.
That was perfect.
Because we always wondered,
so you just opened that door.
Thanks. So, tonight our program
includes both you and Connie --
>> Barbara Freeman: I know.
>> Valda Morris: Back
together again on the stage.
So, what was it like
preparing for this?
>> Barbara Freeman:
It was so much fun.
We met at Connie's house
every time, you know.
We did three sessions.
And, she was telling
me this hilarious story
about Phil [assumed spelling] on
a bicycle ride up the mountain
where you buy these little
clips and, and it was --
it's clearly one of
the funniest things,
but she didn't have
a title for it.
And, so, Phil came up the steps
and I said, Connie, you're going
to call it Spandex
Versus Leather,
but that doesn't tell
anybody anything.
I said, we need an
adjective in front of spandex.
And, maybe one in front
of leather, you know,
to invite people into the story.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah.
>> Barbara Freeman: And Phil
came up the steps and I said,
Phil, your experience where
you kept falling off that bike
because you forgot to click
out your heels with the --
getting the clips off
for your mountain ride,
and so you'd fall over.
And then, the bicyclists
would come by
and say, you all right, buddy?
You'd say, yeah, I'm fine.
It must just be the way
you like to ride then.
You're okay?
I'm out of here.
So, the funny -- the
story is really involved.
But, [inaudible] what would
be an adjective in front
of spandex, which
you had to wear
for your big biking experience?
And he said, dorky [laughter].
And I said, Dorky Spandex, and
then Connie finished it off
Versus Macho Leather [laughter].
So, we had so many laughs.
And then we would stand up and
figure out who stood on the left
and who was on the right.
And, as soon as we did that,
we were off and running.
We just had the best
time with it.
>> Valda Morris: Great.
>> Stephen Winick: So,
do you have any favorite
types of stories to tell?
I mean, you mentioned
that you've gone away
from the dark stories and
toward a certain other kind.
So, what's that experience like?
>> Barbara Freeman:
Well, it's wonderful.
But, when I first did that
I would develop stories
about the saints and
martyrs, and also stories
of when I would go to
churches and stuff.
Maybe they would want a story
about Billy Graham's wife,
Ruth Graham, or if it was
an Episcopalian church,
they wanted a story about
their namesake, you know,
St. Andrew or Saint Philip.
So, I was doing all
this research.
But, when I'd tell those stories
they would appreciate them,
but they wouldn't be as
well developed and --
as the ones that, you know,
I've lived with for 50 years
or something like that.
So, that was a change for me.
But, then I started finding
these really wholesome,
wonderful stories that
really touch your heart.
I'm going to tell one tonight.
It's called Old Joe
and the Carpenter.
And with that story,
I just started --
first of all, when I
was on that airplane,
I asked God to take away
from me my sense of humor
that could take any conversation
and put it into the gutter.
And I said, could you please
just remove that from me,
because that's going to be a
hard place for me to return to,
and I don't want
to return to that.
And, he did.
But, when he -- when he
ripped out the part that --
he took it all [laughter].
So, for -- that was another
reason Connie and I had --
I wasn't funny anymore.
I really wasn't.
And, then when he gave
it back to me, it was --
it was wholesome and, you know,
cute little jokes
and stuff like that.
And, so, when I -- I don't know.
I found story --
He sent me stories.
God sent me stories, like
the Tale of Three Trees,
about three little trees
dreaming what they wanted
to become.
And, I just love that story.
It's one of my favorites.
The Clown of God, about
the juggler who was so poor
and he juggled in a church
one night on Christmas Eve,
and he had no gift
to give the child.
But, he decided to juggle.
And the baby in the statue
of the Blessed Mother
and baby Jesus, the baby was
holding onto the golden ball
at the end of the story.
It's a real sweet thing.
So, I tell just -- I
tell wholesome stories,
but I put my sense
of humor into them.
You know, I tell little side
jokes and stuff like that.
Like tonight for Dry Fry, which
is an old grandfather tale,
I've added that he was
also a veterinarian.
Yes, sir, he was a
veterinarian, and right next
to his veterinary he had
a little taxidermy shop.
It's kind of interesting to have
veterinary next to a taxidermy.
[ Inaudible ]
But, what's most interesting
was the sign he had out front.
Either way, you get
your dog back.
So, you know, stuff like that.
I kind of just inject that,
because that is part
of who I am.
And, so, I can do that with
the saint stories, too,
because there's a lot of funny
things that happen to them.
>> Stephen Winick: All right.
>> Valda Morris:
So, you get these.
So, where do you look
for these materials?
Like, how do you come
up with these materials?
Do you --
>> Barbara Freeman: Well, as a
librarian I really read a lot
of books, and I know the endings
to all of them [laughter].
>> Valda Morris:
Of course, you do.
>> Barbara Freeman: And, so,
it's -- and listening to,
you know, the old-timers
and people that I meet.
And, I tell stories -- for
the last five years I've gone
out to Pisgah View
Dude Horse Ranch
in Asheville, North Carolina.
It's actually a little
down the road in Candler.
And, when I tell stories to
people, I always say at the end
of my little concert that, it's
family reunions and weddings
and stuff like that out
there all the time, I'll say,
does anybody have a story?
And, a lot of times, their
stories are just phenomenal.
And the little kids, too.
They'll do great stories.
So, I get stories from
people and from books and --
>> Stephen Winick: Great.
And, how do you then craft
them into your story?
I mean, how do you make a
performance out of them?
>> Barbara Freeman: Well,
one thing I've always done is
when I hear a story or read a
story I'll tell it immediately.
I'll somebody, even though
I don't know it fully,
I'll just call somebody, or
I'll get somebody to come over,
and I'll try it out on them.
And that's the way
I learn, you know.
I've never been one to
kind of write it all down
or anything like that.
I just treat a story, each
story as if they are my family.
If I tell Dry Fry, he's
one of my family members.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Barbara Freeman:
He's like my uncle.
And, so, I don't have to
worry about remembering it,
because it's happening on the
spot, in the present moment.
And, I try not to know
the ending of a story,
because I don't want to be
thinking, oh, they're going
to love it when I get to
that paragraph that says,
I try not to do that at all.
I just try to tell it, but
be on the spot with it,
and picture my family
members and stuff.
So, I make it real personal.
>> Valda Morris: So, you've
traveled both nationally
and internationally
telling stories.
Can you tell me one of your --
the most unusual place
that you told a story?
>> Barbara Freeman: Now, that's
a good question [laughter].
That would have been
nice if you had called me
on the phone [laughter].
[ Inaudible ]
Well, I'll tell you.
I went to Jerusalem and told
the Tale of Three Trees.
And that's a story about, you
know, one little scene in it --
in it is the tree that
wanted to look up at the --
he looked up to the heavens
and saw the stars
twinkling like diamonds.
And, so, he wanted to be made
into a beautiful treasure chest,
inlaid with gold and silver,
and hold jewels and diamonds.
And, that was his dream
standing on the hillside.
The second little tree wanted
to be a sailing ship made
into a large, important vessel
and carry kings to and fro.
And, the third one, I just want
to stay on the mountaintop.
I don't want to ever leave.
I see the hustle and
bustle of men and women
and children in the valley.
And, I just want to grow
tall, and taller still.
And people, if they want
to see me, they'll have
to raise their eyes, and when
they do, I will point to heaven,
and perhaps they'll
think of God.
I will be the tallest
tree in the world.
And, what ends up is the
first tree is instead taken
to a carpenter shop, once
cut down, and not made
into a beautiful,
magnificent treasure chest,
but a feedbox taken to a farm
for animals to eat out of it.
And then, that develops
later on.
You see that tree years
later as the feedbox.
But, it's a cold
bitter winter night
and golden star light shone
down on the first tree,
as a young mother placed her
newborn babe onto the hay.
Her husband said, I wish I could
have made a cradle for him.
But, that mother, when she
saw that smooth sturdy wooden
and that golden star
light on her babe,
she touched her husband's
arm and she said,
this manger is beautiful.
And, suddenly, the first tree,
he was holding the
greatest treasure on Earth.
And the second one and
then the third one.
The third one is the tallest
tree, because she was left
in the lumberyard, but on a
Friday she was roughly shaken
and removed, carried through
a mob of angry jeering people.
And, she shuddered when a
soldier nailed a man's hands
and feet to her and
she felt sorrow.
But, on Sunday morning, when
the sun rose, you know --
so, she was the tree
of the cross.
>> Valda Morris: Wow, powerful.
>> Barbara Freeman: And, so,
those kind of stories I
just -- I love to find.
That's synonymous by the way.
>> Stephen Winick:
And to tell it
in Jerusalem must have been --
>> Barbara Freeman:
And I told it
in Jerusalem, and it was a hit.
>> Wow.
>> Barbara Freeman: Because I
had just walked the Via Dolorosa
and been to Nazareth on my
birthday, as a matter of fact.
I mean, Bethlehem
on my birthday.
They even sung Happy Birthday
to me and Jesus together
in the same town [laughter].
It's like all right.
I'm living high [laughter].
And those little limber
jacks that I told you about,
that I had 80 of them,
I had called Gail Haley,
she's a famous illustrator
of children's books.
She won the Caldecott
Medal from the Library --
American Library Association.
And, I said, Gail, I
want to go to Holy Land.
It's $999 and I'm going
to sell my limber jacks
and I'm just going to keep two
for the kids, for
kids' programs.
And, she said, Barbara, I've
seen them at book conferences
and festivals that
we've been together.
She said, I'm going to drive
down there, spread them out.
And I had Mini Pearl and String
Bean Ackerman, and horses
and toads and roosters that --
limber jack that
danced, you know.
It was so cute.
And, she said, I'll buy them.
I'll give you $1000.
And I said, that's wonderful.
Isn't that just like the Lord
to give you one lousy
book when you get there?
No, no, it was a blessing.
It was a real blessing.
But, so, yeah, I loved
that trip to Jerusalem.
I've has since been back, too.
It's wonderful.
>> Stephen Winick: Wonderful.
Well, nothing left except to
say thank you to Barbara Freeman
for participating
in this interview.
I'd asked if there's
anything else that you would
like to add just for the record.
>> Barbara Freeman: Well,
Connie and I will tell you,
storytelling, if it ain't true,
it ought to be [laughter].
No, just that, don't be
afraid of storytelling.
Don't say, oh, I could
never tell a story.
It's like me saying, oh, I
could never play the piano.
And, right now I can't.
But, if I practiced and if
I shared that kind of thing,
and if I had in my
heart the desire
for that talent,
you just go for it.
You tell your story and tell it.
You know, don't charge
any money for it.
Just go and volunteer at
the local fire department,
at family reunions,
whatever you can do.
And then, if you find that is
your life's dream, live it.
>> Valda Morris: Thank you.
>> Stephen Winick: Thank
you on behalf of myself
and Valda Morris and the
American Folklife Center.
I'd like to thank
Barbara Freeman
for this wonderful interview.
>> Barbara Freeman: Thank you.
>> Valda Morris: Thank you.
>> Barbara Freeman: That
was great, thank you.
Thank you for the
trick questions, too.
It was great [laughter].
>> Stephen Winick: Alright.
>> Okay.
>> Valda Morris: All
righty [phonetic].
Thank you, that was
wonderful [laughter].
>> Barbara Freeman:
It was so good.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.